we're entering the final two days of
campaigning here we are at Holyrood
today and quite a lot of interesting
things happen today there's been that
big offer of devo max from the three
leaders and the reaction to that well in
the newspapers here seems to be fairly
positive people saying that if you now
vote no there is going to be a big
change for Scotland and for the rest of
the UK whilst if you vote yes you're
going to break up Britain that's the
view of the daily record today and also
interestingly the Glasgow Herald has
come out to say yes has not proven its
case beyond reasonable doubt that leaves
only one paper The Sunday Herald
supporting independence but clearly
there has been a big shift in the polls
from no to yes and the No campaign
desperately trying to stem that now and
hoping that this offer will do a lot of
people saying it should have been there
in the first place and if it had been we
would have voted for it the question is
whether this will now change their minds